Uruguay is about to be the first country
in the world to sell marijuana over the
counter you're gonna sell it over the
counter yeah basically anyone in Uruguay
can literally just walk into a drug
store and buy as much pot as they want
isn't that incredible Andy Andy
[Music]
[Applause]
that is so stupid
plus the law only applies to citizens of
Uruguay
[Music]
[Applause]
why didn't you tell me about the citizen
part all right why would you fly all the
way to Uruguay when there's a pot
dispensary two blocks from here on
Lankershim Boulevard
you knew that did you Andy Andy
so dumb those me it's 11 p.m. they're
closed right now
[Music]
it's 11:00 p.m. they're closed right now
let me get this straight I'm trying to
follow the logic here you took a plane
to go two blocks away yeah I'm a big TV
star I don't know I don't drive I'm
sorry this is awful I just want to
address the audience for a second I'm
very sorry that you had to sit through
this gross abuse of just dumb stock
footage it's just a waste of time right
audience audience
[Music]
[Applause]
so you all got on the individual flights
you understand most asinine
you